Pense num bebê a aprender a andar.
O bebê cai? Sim, muitas vezes.
O bebê diz, só um fracasso.
Não. O bebê simplesmente tenta outra vez.
Cai, aprende, levanta-se.
E um dia, o bebê anda.
É assim que toda aprendizagem funciona.
Aprendemos, cometemos erros, recebemos feedback, melhoramos.
Hoje quero que se lembre de uma frase simples.
Não há fracasso, só feedback.
Vamos repeti-la.
Cada erro ensina-nos alguma coisa.
Cada desafio ensina-nos alguma coisa.
Cada feedback ajuda-nos a torná-lo nos melhores.
Mas só, se estivermos dispostos a aprender.
Um dos maiores jogadores de basketball de todos os tempos, Michael Jordan,
partilhou uma vez uma reflexão sobre a sua carreira.
Contou que falhou milhares de lançamentos e perdeu centenas de jogos ao longo da sua trajetória.
E que essa acumulação de fracasso ao longo de toda a sua vida
foi precisamente a razão pela qual chegou a ser bem sucedido.
Pense nisso.
Um dos maiores atletas da história, não se tornou grande porque nunca falhou.
Tornou-se grande porque aprendeu com fracasso.
Cada lançamento falhado tornou-se feedback.
Cada jogo perdido tornou-se feedback.
Cada erro tornou-o melhor.
O mesmo se aplica a nós.
Talvez hoje cometa um erro no trabalho.
Talvez alguém o corrija.
Talvez o seu chefe lhe mostre uma forma melhor de fazer algo.
Isso não significa que falhou.
Significa que está a aprender.
A pergunta não é, cometi um erro?
Porque toda a gente comete erros.
A verdadeira pergunta é, o que é que aprendi?
Imagine duas pessoas.
A primeira pessoa ouve o feedback e diz,
eu já sei, a culpa não é minha.
Sempre fiz assim.
Esta pessoa deixa de crescer.
Agora olhe para a segunda pessoa.
Ela diz, obrigado.
Pode mostrar-me?
Como posso melhorar?
Esta pessoa cresce todos os dias.
A diferença não é talento.
A diferença é atitude.
A sua relação com feedback
vai determinar o seu crescimento.
As pessoas que crescem mais depressa
geralmente recebem mais feedback.
Não porque são piores,
mas porque estão sempre a aprender.
Fazem perguntas, escutam, melhoram.
Outra vez, fazem perguntas, escutam, melhoram.
Há outra lição importante.
Se quer melhorar,
aprenda com pessoas que estão mais avançadas do que si.
Alguém com mais experiência,
alguém que já resolveu o problema,
alguém que já cometeu os erros.
Por quê?
Porque a experiência dessa pessoa
se torna o seu atalho.
Em vez de aprender tudo da forma mais difícil,
pode aprender com a sabedoria dessa pessoa.
Mas isto exige algo importante.
Humildade.
A humildade diz,
não sei tudo.
Ainda posso aprender.
Por favor, ensinem-me.
Essa atitude vai levá-lo muito mais longe
do que fingir que já sabe tudo.
As pessoas gostam de trabalhar com alguém que aprende,
alguém que aceita feedback,
alguém que melhora,
alguém que diz,
obrigado,
da próxima vez, vou fazer melhor.
Esse tipo de pessoa torna-se digna de confiança.
Esse tipo de pessoa ganha respeito.
Esse tipo de pessoa cresce.
Por isso, lembre-se disto.
Os erros são normais.
Aprender é uma escolha.
O feedback é um presente.
O crescimento é uma decisão.
Erro, feedback, aprender, melhorar, repetir.
Da próxima vez que cometer um erro,
não pergunte, sou um fracasso?
Em vez disso, pergunte.
O que é que isto me está a ensinar?
O que posso fazer melhor da próxima vez?
Que feedback posso retirar disto?
Porque não há fracasso, só feedback.
E cada feedback que eu tenho,
eu tenho um erro.
O que é que isso me está a ensinar?
O que posso fazer melhor da próxima vez?
O feedback é mais uma oportunidade
para se tornar um trabalhador melhor.
Um melhor colega de equipa
e uma pessoa melhor.